my name is Taylor oof I probably drew
before I could you know like read or
talk or anything it's based on my life
and stuff but it's kind of like my world
refined it's kind of like the world I
wish I lived in and stuff most of it
isn't about the you know aesthetics and
it being technically really good because
I'm not a technically super gifted
drawer I don't post it for other people
I post it for me there's not not a
beginning middle and and it's fragments
and I like it that way
my favorite thing about observation is
the self-aware aspect of it you know
being snide and you know the cynical you
know kind of thing but you know you're
kind of the person you're making fun of
as well my personal favorites have just
come from sitting down and drawing
without any pretext or anything and just
drew and you know kind of got it out I
think anybody's best work comes from
that kind of stuff
[Music]